hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
cell mediated immunity so let's just
begin
by looking at the players of cell
mediated immune system
so there are three major players which
plays very important role in this immune
process
they are cytotoxic t cells nk cells are
natural killer cells
and nkt cells so we'll learn about
all of their functions their molecular
details and
how they orchestrate the response
against several pathogens
so the key component of cell mediated
immunity is a cytotoxic t
cell cytodoxic t cell has alpha beta t
cell receptor
but cd8 as a core receptor which is
different from t helper cells
so let's talk about where do these
cytotoxic t cells come from
and we know that the development of t
cell just like other
lymphocytes starts in the bone marrow
in the bone marrow there would be
hematopoietic pluripotent stem cell
giving rise to
common lymphoid progenitor from the
common lymphoid progenitor
t cell precursors would be produced now
once these t-cell precursors are there
in the bone marrow they would be
secreted into the bloodstream
and then the next stage of t cell
development starts in
thymus so in the thymus t
cells would undergo thymic training and
there are
several rounds of training that these t
cells receive
and each of these training ensures some
capabilities are selected in these t
cells so in the thymic medulla
or thymic cortica metallic medullary
junction
there would be some medullary epithelial
cells
which express antigens on top of class 2
mhc or class
1 mhc the t cells the double positive t
cells
which recognize class 2 mhc bound
peptides
they in turn up regulate
cd4 expression whereas down regulates
cd8 expression
in contrast the cells which recognize
class 1 mhc bound peptide
they upregulate the cd8 expression
whereas down regulate cd4 expression
becomes
a cytotoxic t cell so now we know
where does this cytodoxic t cell come
from but these cytotoxic t cells that
are generated inside the
thymus they are naive that means they
have not
encountered any pathogen-derived antigen
yet
so let's see how they actually respond
when they are
activated so first these naive cells
need to be
activated and we know that helper t
cells are activated by dendritic cell
and it turns out that these cytotoxic
t cells can also be activated by the
dendritic cell by a process known as
cross presentation dendritic cell
generally express
class 2 mhc molecule because they are
professional antigen presenting cell
so obviously they show their
pathogen-derived antigen to helper t
cells but these helper t cells in rare
occasions can also
permit the dendritic cell or give this
dendritic cellular license
to present pathogenic antigen on top of
class 1 mhc molecule
now this class 1 mhc molecule
derived a pathogen derived antigen
is actually displayed to cd8 positive
cytotoxic t
cell that leads to activation
of cd8 positive t cell now cd8 positive
t cell once they are activated they are
no more naive
in an activated form they would undergo
several changes and they would engage
to kill the pathogen or kill the
cell which is affected by this pathogen
so let us take an example
these cytotoxic t cell plays a major
role
against intracellular pathogens such as
viruses or by specific intracellular
bacteria
so in this example some of these viruses
has entered this cell which is marked in
yellow
and these virus infected cell would be
displaying some of these
viral proteins on top of
its class 1 mhc molecule
now this class 1 mhc bound peptides
would be presented
to cytotoxic t cells cytoloxic t
cells have a lot of granules
filled up with perforin and granzites
these granules filled up with perfurin
and granzyme helps to
kill the cell which is affected so
perforin creates
pore in the membrane surface allowing
the granzyme to get in
so once the granzyme is inside the
target cell the granzyme
can activate beet now beet is a
mitochondrial protein
which helps in apoptosis pathway bead
allows
leakage of cytochrome c into the cytosol
and cytochrome c
can form a complex with a puff one and
the ultimate consequence
is production of caspase-3
or activation of caspase-3 by
proteolytic cleavage
caspase-3 is the executor caspase
that means caspase-3 would
lead to apoptosis so once caspase-3 is
activated it would generally lead to
apoptosis so in this case we learned
that granzione mediated pathway can lead
to caspase reactivation and thereby
apoptosis
there are other ways by which this
killing can take place that is via fast
and fast ligand-mediated pathway
fast and fast ligand-mediated
interaction can active
caspase-8 i mean cleave caspase-8 such
that the
caspase-8 is activated but caspase-8
unlike caspase-3
is not a executor caspase it's a
initiator casper
so obviously caspase 8 would try to
activate caspase-3 in an indirect
fashion
but ultimately leading to apoptosis so
be it fast mediated pathway or be it
performance mediated pathway
ultima ultimate fate is apoptosis
with the help of cleaved caspase-3 and
the cell would
die and play out along with it
the virus or the pathogens which is
inside it it would also
be demolished now let's talk about the
second cell type in cell mediated
immunity
that is nk cells we can introduce nk
cells
just like a cold blood killer in the
immune system so they are
born and specialized to kill so let's
talk about some
important features of the nk cells nk
cells have set of activatory receptors
and
inhibitory receptors that they use for
their function i'll tell you more about
that
but nk cells are highly loaded with
cytotoxic
granule as you can see nk cells has
their signature receptors in k 1.1
which tells us that this is internal nk
cell
they also have fc receptor and also they
have fast
or fast ligands all of which
can tell us that they engage the
infected cell in a way similar to the t
cytotoxic cell but the detection is very
different
generally there are two type of
interactions happening between a
nk cell and the cell that it engage one
is activatory ligand and activator
receptor mediated interaction
so the inherent tendency is to kill the
cell
but there is inhibitory receptors
which are triggered by class 1 mhc
expression
if class 1 mhc is expressed this
inhibitory receptor would give a strong
inhibitory
signal that would allow this dendritic
cell to disengage
but if this inhibitory signal is not
there
so it would look like a open accelerator
so it would accelerate
the process of killing so obviously if
this signal
is not there the class 1 mhc is not
there then
the nk cells would be free to engage
and it would secrete a hell lot of
perforing and
enzyme ultimately leading to apoptosis
of the target cell
and this lead to destruction and the way
it performs apoptosis is very
similar to cytotoxic t cell it could be
via
perforing enzyme mediated pathway or a
fasciligan mediated pathway
so obviously when a
virus gets virus is infecting a cell
it might play a trick it might lead to
down regulation of the mhc cell
expecting that the cd8 positive t cells
would be confused and would disengage
but these poor viruses don't know there
is a fail-safe mechanism in our body
and that is done by natural killer cells
whose inherent tendency is to kill the
cell and once it would find msc it would
not kill the cell
in this case the msc is severely down
regulated there is not too much surface
expression of
mhc compared to the nearby cells so
obviously
in this cell the nk cell would engage
and try to kill the cell
with apoptosis now let's talk about the
third cell type
nkt cells so nkt cells has a lot of
things common with
both t cell and the nk cell and it was
first discovered in a
mouse and people thought this is
this have a strong resemblance with the
t cell but also it
is associated with the mk 1.1 surface
marker so people were really confused
about
nkt cells and recently people get
to know about nkt cells more
now nkt cells has t cell receptor just
like
other t helper cell or cytotoxic t cell
it has
nk 1.1 which is a bona fide receptor for
nk cells it has
chronzyme and perforin loaded vesicles
it also has fc receptors so few
characteristics
are actually similar to t cell few
characteristics are similar to ng cells
so that kinds of put these cell types in
an interface between these two cells
now these t cell
or nkt cells their receptor is less
diverse
compared to a t helper cell generally
they recognize lipid or glycolipid type
antigens presented on a cd1
molecule which is not exactly a mhc but
it's kind of a mhc
like molecule so obviously the way they
interact or where they recognize the
antigen is very different compared to a
th
cell and they have limited diversity
nkt cell seems to be essential
for several aspects of immunity because
the mouse where nkt
cells are not there or they are
abrogated
in that case the risk of autoimmune
disease is
increased so obviously it has a role to
play in autoimmune disease nkt cells
secrete cytokines that has diverse
effect and it can
secrete diverse cytokines such as il2
il4 interferon gamma or tnf alpha
this il4 and interferon gamma
can help in t cell differentiation into
a th1
subtype or th2 subtype and which has
deep consequence in terms of immune
responses
now tn tnf alpha or il-6 can also invoke
inflammatory responses so these mkt
cells
triggers inflammatory response which is
characteristic feature of these cell
types
obviously they have fc receptors so they
can really
um engulf oxinized pathogen with their
fc receptors
and that is very similar to other cell
types and this is kind of like
adcc mechanism or antibody dependent
cellular cytodoxy
toxicity mechanism so in short these
cells
eliminate targets which are in fact
infected with intracellular pathogen or
intracellular bacteria or a virus also
it has profound role
in case of tumor immunity so all these
features really
make mkt cells are interesting cell type
to study
and active research is going on so let's
look at where does
nkt cell development take place just
like any other t cell
nkt cell development also take place in
the thymus
so in the thymus we know there are
rounds of selection that a t cell has to
undergo to become a mature t cell but
from the double positive t
cell from which the t helper cell and
the cytodoxy cells are born from
the same sub-population nkt cells are
also born
lineage tracing experiments confirm
these observations
but exactly the molecular mechanism by
which an nkt lineage is separated from
this
cytotoxic or helper t lineage is still
not known and a lot of research is going
on in this field
so let us summarize what we have learned
so far we have learned the players of
the cell mediated immunity
mechanism of effector response how
apoptosis is triggered
nk cells response and mkt cells response
so i hope you enjoyed this video and in
this video we get a comprehensive
overview
of the cell mediated immune responses so
if you like
this video give it a quick thumbs up and
don't forget to like share and subscribe
also support me in patreon via patreon
you would get to know a very
wide variety of contents in patreon and
my courses are also present in an
academy so use my code ap 10 to get a 10
discount and unacademy is really
creating a
huge impact in indian education so do
subscribe on academy
thank you guys